hi guys it's naughty MVC editor here at
glam okay I'm Hani I'm with bamas glam
hi Jovie columnist hi guys I'm Sam
Clemens deputy beauty editor and you
were watching
parametrize are we test out with the
latest and greatest in the wonderful
world
[Music]
today I'm going to be trying out the
philosophy purity new skincare range in
a speaker three-day challenge I will be
trying out the cleanser the mask and the
moisturizer as well as a few other
products that we'll see soon
I've just got back to the hotel after a
long day and I've got to remove all my
makeup so I'm gonna call upon the purity
micellar water so gentle so I've taken
off all my makeup I want to give my skin
and more thorough cleanse and that I'm
going to call upon the philosophy purity
three-in-one original cleanser it's
supposed to remove makeup cleanse the
skin and turn the skin just going to use
a pea-sized amount only using one of the
things I lived up about this product
this is my first time actually using a
cleanser to take my makeup off and
actually see my makeup coming off so
wash your skin make sure any residue has
been removed oh my god it's actually
taken all my makeup off the last step in
my skincare routine for tonight we're
going to apply the new purity
moisturizer I need something that's
going to give me that hydration but not
weigh down my oily foreheads I am
excited to try this because I do have
terribly dry skin that's just absolutely
soaked into my skin in about two seconds
it doesn't feel oily or greasy or
anything I told him ready for bed
I'm just waiting in the hotel lobby to
be picked up for my second meeting of
the day but my skin is feeling really
really refreshed and hydrated and it's
looking like really glowy which I'm
absolutely loving so I'm just now
grabbing some lunch and thought I'd do a
quick skin check-in so far so good
I haven't got any dryness I usually get
it a little bit around my nose but it
seems to be staying quite smooth my skin
just feels completely smooth and
flawless and my makeup just literally
slid on and I had no problems with a
plane here so my skin really really
needs a dude
I'm going to call upon the new purity
mask now this has some really impressive
ingredients including white clay which
is going to bring all the dirt to the
surface as well as salicylic acid skin
feels so fresh so smooth I can't tell
you how soft it feels my makeup has been
really really comfortable today it's
looks really natural which I absolutely
adore so it's the end of the day I am
absolutely wrecked but I'm going to be a
good girl and go to the gym I'm going to
give the face wipe to try what I already
love about these is that they're
packaged with a clip container seems to
have pulled most of that off quite well
this is how we're going so far it's been
about 20 seconds we need to get all of
this off so pretty good for a face wet
okay day three we are done with the
philosophy purity challenge my favorite
product me was definitely the
moisturiser my skin loves this normally
my skin gets dry as a crocodile I still
want to keep my face matte but really
hydrated and the moisturizer helped me
kind of do that which I was really happy
about
thank you so much for watching glamour
tries and the philosophy purity
three-day skincare challenge if you like
any other product so if you are going to
try any other products let us know what
you think because we would love to know
please subscribe to glamour UK's YouTube
channel and make sure to follow us on
all our social
[Music]